dany fait partie des artistes qui ont un
pseudo vous appelez dany brillant alors
qu'en fait c'est quoi votre vrai nom
quand cohen d'accord est ce que vous
imaginez nikos sur nrj music awards qui
annonce des artistes avec leur vrai nom
saviez vous c'est david cohen dany cohn
dany cohen d'accord mais je vais vous
les annonces et moi de nikos il va
falloir trouver de clean sèche au ras
d'un petit job ce pour quoi vous appelle
briand déjà j'adore cette anecdote à
chaque fois au pas ce que je vais
raconter plein de fois mais on l'adoré
le cabaret où je passais et je passais
devant des gens qui mangeaient ouais il
fallait retenir leur attention il
fallait avoir du charisme ou fait et le
patron disait toujours que c'est ce soir
savait difficile il faut que tu sois
brillant dany brillant d'années alors
voilà je m'appelle dany brillant
alors attention vous allez essayer de
trouver les noms des artistes
ok c'est parti d'une guerre
les élus ont accueilli un nouvel artiste
entre lui et l'artiste caviste ya du
rififi dans l'air cette fois et vient
nous voir accompagné de son orchestre
philatélistes c et mia farrow bas bonnes
réponses auxquelles attention deuxième
souvient son duo avec l'excellent
laurent voulzy à nourrir ce soit en
exclusivité mondiale c'est vanessa gars
enquête avec tous les looks vanessa
paradis c'est pas du tout ça du tout ça
vanessa dartier pause-café loup mais oui
mais c est beau gély à maman oui mais
moi je suis même pas sûr de la réponse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on enfin autre époque
nous ses tauliers auteur du tube de
grand corps palmade et camille la louche
il a voulu le rendre vraiment hommage ce
soir à sa manière il est avec nous ce
soir luz et christophe martichon
[Applaudissements]
attention les loups et un nouvel artiste
qui donne le choix d'un nouvel artiste
qui va nous rejoindre les loups cet
artiste il était dans le château il
actuellement en tournée avec le chanteur
calogero
il a eu la gentillesse de faire un petit
détour par chez nous en exclusivité
régionale pour les légers music awards
c'est pierre garand égard on ne décèle
pas très gai jamais cette gare où oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean moulin dernier ou pas gerber dont
vous avez quitté ce jeu avait quitté
aussi attention à présent vous émettez
manu payet qui imitent des kwassas où la
lega qu'on nous la scène artistique
française va nous interpréter son
nouveau titre sur musique va le faire
sans aucune musique on atteint poule qu
ils serge chanvrier il sert d'une loi
alors attention celle-ci est très dur
mais nous on va trouver l'artiste nous a
manqué dix ans d'absence a sera de
retour sur la scène musicale au zénith
de tourcoing coin fait une standing
ovation pour laetitia cérébraux et myla
rose hill
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]